[Música]
y en directo América llegó el momento de
hablar de economía por ello le doy la
bienvenida a mi compañero Luis Méndez
Luis iniciamos hablando de Estados
Unidos porque el presidente Joe biden
destacó las buenas noticias que recibió
el país respecto a la economía Así es
Andrés Esto fue durante un discurso en
Springfield donde el jefe de la Casa
Blanca respondió a las políticas
Fiscales republicanas pyren promocionó
el informe económico que fue calificado
como mejor de lo esperado y lo atribuyó
a que las cifras son pruebas de que sus
plan está funcionando a pesar de una
política de endurecimiento de medidas y
alzas en los tipos de interés como parte
de la lucha contra la inflación
escuchemos
recibimos muy buenas noticias sobre la
economía estadounidense cada tres meses
las perspectiva económica de Estados
Unidos se presentan un informe oficial
un informe de gobierno salió esta mañana
y no estoy seguro de que las noticias
puedan haber sido mejores
el crecimiento económico ha aumentado
más fuerte de lo que esperaban los
expertos en un 2,9% y sigue creciendo
ese crecimiento de dos coma nueve por
ciento es a tasa anual pero el
crecimiento trimestral durante el último
periodo del año se ubicó en 0,7% y en
general la economía estadounidense se
expandió 2,1 puntos porcentuales pero
lejos del 5,9% registrado en el año 2021
biden también lanzó una advertencia a
los republicanos escuchemos
es por eso que los republicanos
eligieron deliberadamente infringir este
tipo de dolor sobre el pueblo
estadounidense por qué porque esta
nación ha pasado por demasiado Hemos
llegado demasiado lejos para permitir
que eso suceda y no permitiré que suceda
Luis cambiamos el tema y pasamos a China
porque la flexibilización de las medidas
contra el Coby 19 han impulsado al
turismo en el gigante asiático Así es
esto durante las vacaciones del festival
de primavera que han experimentado un
auge y se espera que se reanuden los
viajes grupales a partir del próximo 6
de febrero la reserva de boletos aéreos
cuadruplicó este año países como
filipinas Indonesia y Vietnam le han
dado una calurosa bienvenida a los
turistas chinos organizando los
funcionarios locales para que celebren
ceremonias de bienvenida en el
aeropuerto se espera que las agencias de
viajes y los operadores turísticos en
línea de China puedan reiniciar los
viajes grupales y ofrecer paquetes de
aerolíneas y hoteles a partir del 6 de
febrero Pero en medio de esta situación
un informe de la ONU señala que el
crecimiento de la producción industrial
se desacelerará este año se espera que
el crecimiento económico de China se
expanda un 4,8% en este 2023 Luis y
pasamos ahora a nuestra región ya que un
préstamo para Argentina podría llevar a
esta nación a convertirse en exportador
de gas como es eso se desprende un
informe del Ministerio de economía donde
se explica que el país acordó un
préstamo con el banco de desarrollo para
América Latina por 540 millones de
dólares estos recursos podrían cambiar
la situación actual donde Argentina le
compra gasa a Bolivia desde el año 2006
pero estas compras son cada vez menores
el dinero se destinará la construcción
de un gasoducto al tiempo que se
utilizará la infraestructura actual para
llevar gas en sentido inverso y aumentar
las posibilidades de volúmenes de
exportación de Cat a chile y a Brasil
Luis y ahora en una información de
empresas la Automotriz Renault podría
incrementar los salarios de sus
trabajadores una muy buena noticia para
ellos así se desprende una información
de la agencia de noticias router que
cita Fuentes anónimas cercanas a las
negociaciones según reuters estaría
ofreciendo los trabajadores aumentar su
presupuesto para salarios en un 7,5% en
este año Así ayudará a hacer frente al
aumento en el costo de la vida según las
fuentes el incremento presupuestario
equivaldría un alza salarial neto de 110
euros al mes para cerca de dos tercios
la plantilla de acuerdo con el reporte y
representaría el mayor aumento desde el
año
2992 la noticia se presenta un día
después de que En España se conociera
que el salario subirá este año un 5,9%
como resultado de la aplicación del
convenio colectivo de esta empresa
establecido con medio punto superior a
la previsión de inflación y otro medio
punto adicional vinculado al
cumplimiento de objetivos dentro de su
plan Industrial Luis momento de conocer
Los indicadores los indicadores en
Estados Unidos cerraron de manera
positiva sobre todo por los datos
económicos mostrados el día de hoy una
situación que también se trasladó a los
mercados europeos que abrieron con
números positivos Y cerraron con números
positivos todo esto dada las previsiones
de unas mejoras económicas dentro del
panorama en occidente por otro lado
también en América Latina hubo números
mixtos en la jornada registrando la
caída en la bolsa de Brasil Cuál es
nuestra cifra del día tiene que ver en
este caso con los datos de desempleo en
España porque allí se crearon
278.900 puestos de empleo en el año 2022
y el desempleo Tuvo una reducción de
79.900 personas en ese periodo un 2,6%
menos que en el año 2021 Luis Méndez con
la información económica Muchas gracias
seguimos con más en directo América